um
i'd like to welcome everyone um both in
the room
and live streaming to the april 7
edition of the infrastructure
services committee and the cargo city
council
so we're going to start with
uh we've got some zoom attendees and
they are
councillor abbott possibly counsellor
munsden later but i've got her down as
an apology
uh his worship the mayor may be zooming
in
maybe right and now to apologies i do
have one for a
councillor munson for the start of the
meeting she's
unfortunately traveling at the moment so
i'll move that can i have a second to
please
second thank you councillor so far
i'll put that all those in favor
right we're going to move on now to we
have a
public forum
and we have dr martin lipsky
to speak to us in regards to
for affordable housing
welcome muscle thank you kiera
before i start because i'll be speaking
potentially in near future on
other aspects to the council on oh just
sorry to interrupt you here five minutes
i am aware i just want to point out that
i hope the
trust in the council being able to
separate the problem from the person and
it's not going to influence my future
speaking
as you can see from the material that i
have provided
hopefully there should be a graphic i
don't actually know how exactly
to start this i should have a strong
start
but as a young person you might feel at
the end of my five minutes
i'm frustrated or angry but i'm rather
extremely depressed by the fact that
it's impossible to buy a property as a
young person nowadays
and that there is nothing and the whole
system including the council
the banks and anyone really that
provides help
and support for i call them home house
buyers not first home
first home buyers because the word first
home buyers implicates i'll be investing
in it
as you see from the material
buying property has a entry cost the
entry cost is about 500 to 600
000 the average price doesn't mean
anything because the average price
includes small properties sections and
the town consisting of old houses that
are moldy
shouldn't be really actually used
they're going to fall apart and have a
high cost and if i'm not environmentally
friendly you have a small footprint
yet there is affordable housing that
exists
whatever the government has proposed
recently and changes to
taxes or percentages it's not gonna fix
the problem that there's people out
there
who cannot afford those five hundred to
six hundred thousand dollars
because people can maybe afford a house
for two hundred or three hundred
thousand dollars
and those houses exist those houses are
tiny houses those houses are kit
houses modular houses they all exist
yet the banks are not gonna
mortgage it literally yet
the council doesn't even allow for
example me building a garage and living
in a garage sleepout
and that's just depressing the fact that
there's solutions out there
people talk about affordable housing yet
no one seems to want to actually do
something
about it to allow these solutions to
exist to be
actually built
and how is someone
remotely possibly
able to invest 500 to 600 thousand on a
small property it's actually easier for
me to go out there and buy an old
section
small section of an old house and the
bank will just hand me any money i want
because if i want to buy a section of
any size
put a environmentally friendly new tiny
home
model home on it i'm not going to get a
single cent they're actually that
bad they're going to ask me up to 50 sbs
the great sps is asking up to 50 percent
of deposit
on a land-only mortgage so if i wanted
to actually pay for my land myself
for a small section beside the outside
of the city
and then you know mortgage the house i
can't do that
so from my point of view you know that
sooner or later tiny houses kit houses
will be all allowed to build so rather
than waiting for another council another
part of new zealand to allow there's
another part of the world really
i'm asking you very kindly please act on
that
please actually do something about
affordable housing because you have the
power to do so
you have the power to help young people
to build
cool affordable nice warm high-tech
modern houses
because right now it's just depressing
thank you
okay i'm going to open up the floor now
for questions
first we have council adelaide thanks
chairman old
through you um ask for clarification
from maybe darren to see whether and i'm
pretty sure there's nothing in the
district plan that prevents
tiny houses from being constructed can i
just
seek some clarification on that
darren are you able to comment on that
sure um district plan
allows for the building of
small houses it would be interesting to
understand
i think what the concept of the small
houses looks like
um
this um further that does nothing to the
council but the bank also refuses
to provide a mortgage if there isn't
water energy
and sewage provided so if i want to go
off grid
if i want to actually be modern
environmentally friendly and have my own
sewage tank if i want to have solar
if i want to have you know power from
that
actually i'm going to get a mortgage
independent it doesn't matter what i
built
can we just keep it to what council can
do rather than what the
financial world is is doing yeah
um nigel council scott martin thank you
for your passion
i think it's fantastic a young person
has come in and addressed what is
obviously a massive issue for young
people i have two young daughters also
in the same
situation and a personal one but
understand your passion and understand
where it's at there are there are models
worldwide that have gone into modular
housing and so on and it's been very
successful along with the
environmentally friendly aspect
as well so i guess it's about um
the opportunity of taking a leap forward
and have you got any further suggestions
in the sense or
how you might approach it given our
situation in the sense of a council
it's always good because you've
obviously thought about it i just wonder
why these restrictions
are so tight
i if i as a young person commit to a
up to 30 year old mortgage and put
myself in this position where i am
actually adapting myself for half of my
life
i own technically the land after you
know half the time because i don't
really own it until i paid 50
off right why can i not build what i
want on the land
like that's a very i know that's a very
leisurely approach and it takes all
restrictions over but
should i think it should be approached
from the other side if someone owns this
piece of land
by you know high risk high commitment
if i want to live in my garage why
why is the council setting the living
standard
that's my question the reverse question
i know it doesn't answer a question i do
but
i think just giving more freedom and
allowing people to build on that what
they want
uh darren would you like to comment on
the living standard
sort of a health and health aspect and
stuff
regulations yeah
so council is tasked with ensuring
a council is tasked with ensuring that
houses are built to code and the code is
set through uh legislation uh through
central government
past administered through uh the
ministry for business
innovation and employment so it's
incumbent upon us to ensure that those
standards are adhered to
again what you will find here in
invercargill
is that we're very progressive in our
approach to administering
the legislation the district plan and
the building code
and we're more than happy to work with
any
willing homeowners home buyers first
home buyers
who are wanting to explore what
opportunities are out there for them
so that obviously applies to the
building code and the resource
management code
not banking that is correct yet
tiny houses are consented they build it
on consented
legislation kit homes most of them have
nz consent
and yet it's not that actually easy as
you have pointed it out to build it
because even
when i went to versatile which was the
only one who i was recommended i know by
banks to
that's part of that's not the council
problem
they even instantly said no we're not
going to build your sleep
out house or barn house because it's
very hard to get for council
okay uh council adelaide then councillor
through you chair can i just check with
uh possibly darren as to
whether or not if somebody is building
on a property at which it's possible to
be connected to water and sewage
even though they don't there is still a
charge that applies
but if they are building on a property
to which there are no
services then the builder would
surely just be required to show proof
of an effective um uh
um a sewage treatment system on site
um again through you cheer um correct so
the district plan
outlines what the conditions are and how
they are to be met
if the solution is acceptable
more than happy to work through that but
we simply can't
just let any solution whether it's
certified or uncertified be put in place
without consideration
thank you council lewis thank you chair
i was going to ask dr dr a similar
question
to do with the the sewage septic tank
type regulations which
command a certain acreage for disposal
of some of the effluent
and wonder if if any of these
economical houses that you talk about
i've often read them in magazines i'm
sure you have
started extensively um some of them may
be
more expensive even to buy with to build
would they with the composting systems
and the
the uk regulations no
no no no way no way like and
it depends on the size but i was asking
yes
the question is very similar counselor
and the responsibility
yeah like for example in sewage i don't
have the numbers
but uh property on omar we about five
hectares i had to
get a cable for electricity 500 meters
just the is 90 000 so i'm pretty much
if i want to do that i'm building
infrastructure for the council
and excuse me but
if the alternative of solar is around 30
000
and that's not considered that's just a
cable the ninety thousand dollars i have
to pay another fifteen plus
fifteen to twenty thousand for a
transformer on a pole closer to
a street or something other that so it's
about 100 grand to connect myself to
um central electricity services again
this does not
see which doesn't answer this question
particularly but um
i'm very much put off of it going that
way
if that's the cost of electricity point
of clarification chair electricity
connections are not council
infrastructure
correct they are not council
infrastructure um right
councillor scout i'm going to be the
last one here because we've exceeded the
10 minutes council skill
thank you to um it's very concerning to
have a young man come in and tell us
he's depressed
um and this young man i know um
does a lot in our community so for him
to come into this arena
and tell us that that's admirable to say
the least
and i accept we can't fix the banks
at all that's that's not our issue i
understand and it's really encouraging
to hear darren to say that
our council this council is
exceptionally positive around all
solutions and solutions driven around
housing and
what we can and what we can't do and so
there's maneuverability around all that
i think what we need to be able to do
though is to give you some hope
because we haven't got to hope we must
pack up the bag and the tool kit
the people there's people living in all
sorts of things worldwide they're living
in
containers and living in whatever around
the world there's many many many
examples
so it would be unjust for this council
just to dismiss what you've presented
today
somehow between us whatever we need to
think
outside the square and we just sit down
and see if it's a
generic feeling across our young people
that it's become so difficult and see
what and if if indeed there is anything
we can do
as a council to help so plea to the rest
of the council's um let's not dismiss
this
it's actually a relatively important
point
okay so i'm gonna uh
okay one okay
one counselor class one sorry
thank you um it's just uh you know like
as a young person myself sitting here
listening to um what you've had to say
dr lipsky um i'm also
a little bit gutted that counselor
edmundson isn't here because this is
right up her alley she's very involved
in building regulation regulatory
and the district plan has been super
involved in
um housing with the southern housing
action forum i think this forum yeah and
um
i also know personally quite a few
people in the city
boundary that have tiny homes and have
successfully built
tiny homes that are living um off-grid
and i think
for off the top of my memory the way
that they kind of got around
once they got around this they still
have very excellent standards
um to the building code um little tiny
homes
but they had them on remote they're
movable
so that they they can you know plumb
them and they can
wire them up they can you know get
services listed
um and into the council networks for
reticulation water articulation and
sewage and such
but they're also on a trailer so they're
movable when they
um you know so they sort of so they're
like
um darren has said i'd like to think
that the city
is progressive and that those sort of
things you know
can be achieved if that's if you can
find a way like unfortunately we can't
fix it
but to finance it this i think might be
the
challenging issue i know that's not this
issue that's just
a joke i know that's not supposed to be
said here but
yeah from that perspective is joke but
it would be lovely if i didn't need to
go around
yes that would be lovely yeah okay thank
you very much marcel for
coming in okay right we're gonna
move on
to interest resist interest and register
that remains updatable at any time for
anyone
so i haven't had any additions to that
we'll go now to the minutes
of the
infrastructure services committee held
tuesday second march can i please have
someone move that those
minutes be received thank you mr
councillor scott
second counselor crack it'll put that
emotionalism in favor
hi and that's carried now we move
to the minutes of the extraordinary
infrastructural services committee held
monday 29th march you can have someone
move
let me receive thank you councillor
sapper second
seconded councillor crackit put the
motion all those in favor
all right against that has carried now
i'm going to move now
to temporary road closures and we have
mr pearson russell welcome
good afternoon thanks mr chairman this
is a report that seeks
to identify a number of
temporary road closures for our city
streets that are based around obviously
the anzac parade
and some work we plan on the innovative
streets to activate the inner city
and for a closure for gala street
the legislation requires us to actually
seek council approval for those
because it's of an event status
okay thank you um we have three
recommendations in front of us to um
get this through but i'm going to open
it up now for any
comments happy to move the
recommendations chair thank you council
ello happy to second them this chair
thank you councillor sopa so no further
discussion
put the motion all that all those in
favor all right
yes that is carried thank you russell
next item is the q park
reserve classification
and welcome caroline
good afternoon your worshipping
councillors um this is a procedural
report
to allow the resolution from a paper
that we brought you last september
um and surround the um
request to move from the adjoining
landowner they exchanged the land
located at ellis road part of queue park
macro street for the purpose of
developing mixed model
residential housing at queue park
and what we found is the first step is
to
move this land classified as a reserve
and to then progress to a land exchange
thank you for that okay any comments
regarding this seems pretty
straightforward i have a question
counselor kit thank you
it doesn't actually say here but is it
going to close
one entrance way up and open another or
there'll be
dual entrances to um this block of land
one from ellis road and the other from
macquarie street
good job chapter leslie on that one
please um three
chair um yes the proposal is to open two
entrances into the new subdivision
right thank you
councillor cracker and then council
saber thank you mr chair um this is the
second time we've had
a report on this piece of land um
previously it wasn't packed up that
we needed to have the classifications
um switched over or such so
i'm happy with this explanation and for
us to continue with
basically giving effect to the first
resolution we've made
thank you council sapa thanks mr chair i
was just going to comment in in light of
what a submitter has said in noting that
this is a
future mixed model residential
development
which council has supported on a
significant piece of land
this may be indeed that
part of the mix model may tie in very
nicely with what the submitter has
talked about today thank you
okay any more discussion
in that case can i have someone please
move the recommendations
thank you council adelaide secondary
councillor lewis
i'm going to put the two recommendations
there all those in favor against
the recommendations carried thank you
we now have the activity report and
um who would like to anyone want to
speak to that erin
killed no worries at all so
uh chair and counsellors i'll take the
report
as read and open the floor to
any questions on the content
okay council adelaide thanks chair
through you if we could
pass on feedback under your capital
projects the the falweek gates
uh was opened and and councillor skelton
myself and his worship were there the
morning they were opened um
you know we took a reasonable degree of
feedback during the construction of that
and and
i think um staff should be congratulated
on
um on the job that that's been done and
certainly there's been a lot of positive
feedback that we've heard
since additionally may i commend the
staff
for their engagement and the pilot play
activation
project that they've done in partnership
with healthy families as well
again it's another one of those
innovative things that it's really
pleased to say
see council taking a leadership role in
so thanks for that
any other questions counselor
thanks mr chair i just wanted to remark
on the park's community engagement
and say that that's been noticed
and commented on in the community and it
is it is great air parks has a tradition
of that sort of community engagement i
think good on you for continuing to
engage in some of the same ways but also
new and innovative ways
okay no other discussion on the activity
report
every move it's received thank you
council ludlow secondly
secondary council of soper i'm going to
put the motion that will be received all
those in favor
aye aye against that's carried now
there's no urgent business
um before we go into
public exclude i just want to say
there's a short workshop
after publicly excluded to deal with
our continuing discussion on waste
services and stuff
so that's directly after public excluded
right um i'll move that we now go into
public excluded
surely reasons of uh confirmation of the
minutes and the land disposal five one
five
far away there you go seconded council
care to put the motion all those in
favor
carrie thank you um members of
you